this was a guy I called last night
because he said call anytime and I took
him up on that certainly when I saw him
all over the first episode of all last
night's the last dance and he was over
the second episode too he was really in
the middle of everything in his first in
with the Bulls and then we saw him in
his moment with Charlotte last night
during the last dances he gave a little
bit of the business to Jordan and the
Bulls bench when they eating a game
winning shot in the playoffs for
Charlotte who is with at the time our
buddy BJ Armstrong back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you BJ oh well and
you know you and you guys are family so
you called here we are and then you call
any time
right back at you on that now I'm
wondering what it's like to watch back
moments of your glory and also knowing
that you're barking at the bench no Dow
added fuel to the fire
what do you sit there and go great shot
but please don't don't yell at the bench
do you do that when you sit in there
last night BJ well you know now in my
age now I'm looking like what were you
doing what were you thinking right so
flick it up myself cool okay what were
you thinking about and but back then I
didn't know any other way other than to
capture it so as a young man that's what
you do and that's how I learned how to
play is you lay it out on the line you
play you come to win you come to compete
so you know I've been on the other side
of you know the winning and I've been on
this side of losing and the one thing
you always want to establish especially
when you're in the playoffs is that you
know what you came to fight you came and
you were going to bring the energy that
was necessary but it was funny I I was
laughing the whole time but it was just
so funny to think about you know playing
and and all of those things that you do
and you know what you get caught up in
the game and the emotion and certainly
was it was a big win for us as we were
starting that series out even the series
1-1 but as always you know Michael and
the Bulls they made the adjustments and
they Vinci eventually they wanted
in shipped a year they they won the next
three games against us but certainly I
was laughing it just I was just really
in tears laughing about the whole about
the old incident I bet our better you
kids watching and just see what dad's
doing and it's funny that's why I was
laughing it's so funny to see their
respect they're like that what do you
what were you doing that's what you do
you know if you go to play a play if
you're not then go sit down so but it's
been fun and all our friends and former
teammates and guys they're you know they
make fun of you and it's fun to relive
those signs but you know like that
that's the game we all played and we had
fun doing it and everyone has a sense of
humor about it now so it's uh but it was
those were fun times were both like some
good member beejey Armstrong here on the
Rich Eisen show what was it like to
where were you when you found out Jordan
was retiring for the first time where
were you um you know the one thing I I
do recall is that it happened very close
to the season I think where was only
like two or three days before we were
about to start training camp or
somewhere around over October yeah yeah
sometime in like October sometime it was
right like right before so you know the
one thing that you know I remember is
that we didn't have time to like prepare
for this moment and you don't just lose
you know um we thought like we were
losing a family member right you know
and yeah we were just a great player but
we were more concerned about you know
the person and what he was going through
in his life and his you know his
personal life and then we didn't have
time to put together the team or get
ourselves ready or try to figure out how
we were going to play it was like it
happened it happened quickly and by the
way we have a season about to start so
um you know what I remember most about
that season was you saw the emergence of
Scottie Pippen and that's the one thing
and I I always recall and to never lose
sight that you know Scottie Pippen was
an MVP you know caliber player that year
he had an amazing season I would always
argue that that was probably
just best season individually that he
had and he was just incredible I mean
for you to go from the number-two guy to
the number-one guy and then consistently
he was consistently hands-down a
top-five player and he could have easily
been the MVP of the league that year and
that's what allowed us to make that
transition because there was no time to
do it I mean we all were just kind of
doing this on the fly and then we ended
up winning 55 games a year we ended up
taking the next seven games and the
conference semifinals so it was a very
successful year that we had and everyone
just kind of did it and moved on and
field did a great job as well coaching
that might be probably his finest hour
as well coaching individually because we
had to figure it out as we went along
well and and putting it all together
would you just said BJ the the seventh
game against the Knicks you got to it
because Kukoc made the shot in Chicago
when Scottie wouldn't come off the bench
so that was such a fascinating part of
last night's last dance documentary were
you all surprised in the in the huddle
that that Phil called to play for Tony
and not Scotty well you're in the moment
you're just trying to figure out how to
win the game we had played well enough
to win that game and we had a sense of
desperation because we were already down
Oh - so that was a must game for us as
we were coming back home and sometimes
you know as a player you'd have a feel
some time as a coach you have a feel and
you know what it wasn't a matter if it
was right or wrong I understood where
Scotty was coming from I understood and
I and I got where Bill felt that that
was the best opportunity for us to
potentially win that game and you know
it was just you know it happened you
know when I remember a plane it was
happening but I couldn't get sidetracked
with that you know because we still have
to figure out how to win this game so
Tony hits the shot and what I read the
one thing I do remember still I can like
it happened yesterday was the speech
that Bill Cartwright gave I mean it was
one of the most heartfelt speeches I've
ever seen and Bill was clearly
you know he was he had so much wisdom
and what he brought to that moment
because that moment could have gone a
bunch of different ways but bill was
able to somehow resolve the issue where
you know everyone in that room
understood what had just happened and
Bill didn't have a lot of things to say
you know he chose his words carefully
but he he said what needed to be said
and he brought so much passion I
remember you know you know he was he was
in tears about what happened because we
cared about Scottie we cared about our
group we had come too far and done too
many things and experienced too many
things to allow anything on the outside
to disrupt this group so you know to
this day I took my hat off the bill that
was one of the great moments and my
basketball career of having an
opportunity to see leadership at its
apex and that was one of those moments
because it needed to be said and he said
it we resolved it we moved on and we
were able to play and win the next game
and actually almost win that series so
what did you think of when you heard
Scottie say last night that he would not
have changed that moment that he would
not have gone back and handled it
differently if he had the opportunity
yeah you know I like what else chuckle
right and I took it when I heard that
because I I know Scottie and I know you
know the pressures that it takes to be
you know in that position and I can only
imagine what he was feeling at that time
and I can only imagine all of the things
that we all were feeling right we all
felt the burden of allowing New York to
come back and tie up that game so I got
it but I do know this when the game when
the game has to be played and what we
were gonna do
we knew Scottie was going to be there
and he knew we were going to be there
for him so it was like one of those
things it was said but you know what
Scottie is our guy we love him and we
know the type of guys and relationship
that we have with one another and and
you go on so but I I laugh when I
when I heard that because you know what
it was just like yeah you know you you
you you do things and we all saw what
happened but the thing is as a group as
a team we're always going to figure out
things and that was what I knew about
our group we will figure it out as we go
along
so one of the things that we laugh about
BJ here on our show Chris Brockman and I
and the rest of us watching this
documentary is Kukoc his reaction does
he think you're all just totally insane
I mean just the Americans are just
insane when I first met Tony like it was
like in 1984 and 85 we played against
each other in high school and Tony has a
sense of humor and being around him you
catch it but it's really funny because
he talks that way like like hey what's
going on do you really know every time
just like I'm just trying to play my
game I'm just trying to be myself and
these people are insane like you know
Krauss and I'm just trying to win a game
that's basically what it looks like and
he's like he was like a straight face so
it makes it funnier that's really a
really good catch right yeah thank you
BJ Armstrong here on the Rich Eisen show
few more minutes left with with BJ so
you're sitting around one day and
Michael Jordan who is left
White Sox camp because of the labor
dispute with baseball he calls you up
and he's just asked you what's going on
and you eventually invite him to the
Berto Center and suddenly he's coming
back so my question for you is if you
didn't invite him to the Berto Center
with the comeback have happened or do
you think he called you up and no and
he's already coming back
and you were just part of the plan I
have the idea I'm gonna I'm gonna say
the ladder I think I was as part of the
plan right you know I think he like in
the end I don't know what it was I just
knew that I rich wanted just to be a
good friend mighty to always peace
always be there for me he would always
call me during the season I was calling
him and we were just checking in on one
another to make sure things were good
and the one thing I wanted him to be and
one thing I wanted him to know was that
hey whatever you need we're always here
and you're always welcome and that
you're not alone or whatever you have
going on and and that was it so when he
did call or however we got together you
know I was just like okay let's let's
you know you know see what's going on I
haven't seen him in a while and it was
good and once that one thing led to
another and we were talking and we kind
of liked it just kind of just happened
but I firmly believe that hey you know
that all of us right all of us the
entire team the group we always we
always wanted him to know that that he
was part of our group and we always
wanted to know that whatever he had
going on he always had a home if he
could come there and share that with us
so you know I don't know what it was I
knew he felt comfortable enough to come
back in come back in the building
continue talking all the trash that he
talks see the big personality that he
was but more importantly to be one of
the guys and and that was great for him
I thought it was great for the game and
I you know here I'll just say I'm taking
no credit for that because in the end
you know you just want to see your
friends happy and that was one of the
great moments for all of us because we
picked up where we left off and everyone
was just talking trash he's still
talking to everyone he's doing his thing
and it was a it was a great moment for
all of us because everyone was happy to
see him when he did walk it back I mean
when he did come back in the building
well the his thing BJ
was front and center is part of the
documentary last night and whether it
was something that was right
obviously it was something that needed
to happen in order to win and bring
everybody along with him and understand
what you needed to do in order to be in
his orbit but the question is his thing
was it sometimes too much you even ask
the question they included in in the
documentary is he a nice guy or not
and we saw Jordan at one point say you
know if you don't agree with it
it means you haven't won anything which
is defined if not if not only you know
insulting to some people potentially but
then you could see he broke down he
broke down talking about the pressure of
having that attitude what did you think
of when you saw that last night
BJ well I think Richie knows you know
when this first started you know I kind
of always I had this I was a little bit
I didn't know how this was gonna turn
out because I I know that side I know
that side of him that he's competitive
and I know what it could look like from
the outside looking in but I also know
that if you're gonna make a commitment
to excellence you got to make this
commitment either you're all in and
you're all out the thing rich about him
that I know in that we all know and I
think we're seen and I think there
probably won't go there in episode 9 and
10 is that rich he'd loved the game and
he had this respect for the game at the
highest level right the the goal wasn't
to be the greatest player the goal
wasn't to be the leading you know vote
getter or you know MVP of the league or
to be the considered whatever it is
people want to debate about his goal was
to respect the game to the highest level
and always hold it as the number one
priority in his life and which that is
very difficult right sometime life gets
in the way well somehow he managed to
have the discipline to love the game to
that degree because rich you know why
would someone care that much he's a
cheese everything individually he's
achieve everything with his team but he
loved the game that much where he cared
and that rich has a vulnerability to it
that I understood he cared rich and you
don't practice the way you practice you
don't figure out how to prepare yourself
the way he was preparing himself unless
you truly truly care and he'd loved the
game of basketball he was an artist who
dedicated his life to the craft and
that's what I was concerned about
because when you are living their life
that vulnerable
you saw his vulnerability you saw how he
broke down you meant I mean emotionally
you saw how he prepared himself you saw
how he pushed himself there was no
reason for him to do that other than
there was this innate love that he had
for the game and I got it like I got
that I didn't find a problem playing
with him because I would saw something I
knew I was never going to see again in
my life someone who loved what they did
to the maximum level and was willing to
do whatever you know he never cheated on
line drills he never cheated the game of
basketball and everything he did was
with this one focus in mind and I just
admired it from afar and I think all of
us knew what he was committed to like he
made a commitment with his life to the
game of basketball and no one can argue
that Vijay really appreciate the time as
always and I'll screw it I'm just I'm
booking you for next week - we got to
get there - since when we're through
this whole thing
what for sure well thank you raise any
time you guys well stay safe you too
that's BJ Armstrong three-time NBA
champion and again one of the three
players the year after Jordan left to
make the all-star game Scottie Pippen
Horace Grant and BJ Armstrong hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here